you know it's August out there it
certainly is there are some people who
were probably wondering what month it
was and turned on Late Night with Conan
O'Brien to find out no work is done
let's go yeah good night everybody know
this is the time of year it's a
beautiful time of year actually people
get some vacation mm-hmm you got to get
outdoors got to get outdoors you know
and a lot of people actually go camping
mm-hmm and ladies and gentlemen Andy and
I have for years we've known each other
five years now we're always talked about
hey would it be great if the two of us
could get away just go camping sometime
like real buddies
yeah real amigos yeah we're both we're
both very big outdoorsmen exactly mm-hmm
because people can tell from our on-air
personalities exactly so so we did just
that actually a couple of days ago Andy
and I packed up all our gear put on our
hiking boots and we went camping in the
great American wild and we had a
terrific time and we actually brought a
film camera with us and filmed the whole
thing and well ladies and gentlemen
enjoy Andy and I going camping
[Music]
[Applause]
that's just like a good spot
just just build the tent around me okay
look what I brought you got a lot of
great food to cook but can't cook it
without firewood you got to have an open
fire to cook your food when you're
camping so we're gonna take care of that
right now
whoa look out there's a spider
[Music]
snack snack e handy snack pudding oh
great let's have some of those spam you
like spam yeah so spam I'll open that up
I'm quite you know Andy the Indians used
to cook eggs like this uh-huh which is
why you don't see any of them anymore
and next time we should get unscented
toilet paper okay get your sleeping bag
out shake it out before week
[Applause]
[Music]
folks this is John Harington he's the
chief Ranger here at the park and I
guess the first question we have for you
is do people mistake you a lot for
Wilford Brimley you like oat bran what
is it what does he have fired up about
oat bran sure oh shoot this is John can
I have Welch speech please Welch speech
this is John we've got a sasquatch out
here I've never seen anything like it
did you put on a bear suit for us
no would you put on just the bare head
you just take a second you put it on for
a second we just want to tell people
when we get back home that we saw a bear
they're driving a recreational yeah you
don't do it then one of us is going to
do it hmm can you just put it on for a
second it's just a bear head we have the
bear head right over here bring it over
right now hurry you could just drive
this thing like just not even that far
describe it just a little bit
I'll turn
for you right no I like the three were
unknown it's really not necessary
that's great
take these broken wings Nazi goodbyes
too good word okay school I'm sorry I'm
sorry I know I interrupted the light he
dies let me just load you up there and
then I heard the words the words I had
been dreading ladies and gentlemen David
Hasselhoff and then the curtains opened
and there he was
every hideous six-foot-two inch of him
and he came towards me came towards me
like a like a monster
and he didn't shake my hand
well I haven't slept much since then
some people say or if the kid is in
these woods it may be some time in the
middle the night when I'm asleep
she'll come into the tent and I'll have
to interview her again by John John you
see you will never forget you while
we're here on our own I told you we
should have knocked him out and took
that thing hmm now what
[Applause]
get up there folks tomorrow right it's
beautiful we'll take a break everybody
when we come back ladies dumb and bring
out all his crazy animals Jim Fowler is
gonna be here someone will get hurt
again